اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا نحيكم
الى بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا المساء
تتحدث عن لقاءات رانيا امريكيه مباشره
لاول مره منذ خمس سنوات هي خطوه اولى نحو
التفاهمات في بعض الملفات ام لا تزال
الخلول بعيده
في ظل حكمه طالبان تعليم الافغانيات بين
المنع والتسميم هل هي خطوات لاجبار جميع
الفتيات على ترك الدراسه ام هو تحد يدفعهن
لاسترجاع حق مسلوب
وفي موضوع نقاش اساس اردوغان يعلن تشكيله
حكومته الجديده بوجوه واسماء بارزه
منعكاساتها على سياساتها الخارجيه وعلى
مستقبل العلاقه مع سوريا
ونقلت عن شخص مقرب من الاداره الامريكيه
قوله ان المحادثات
ركزت في المقام الاول على امكانيه التبادل
الاسرى مع ايران اذ تحتجز طهران ما لا يقل
عن ثلاثه مواطنين امريكيين ايرانيين
واعتبرت الصحيفه انه يمكن ان يؤدي الى
تبادل ناجح للاسرى في الولايات المتحده او
مع الولايات المتحده الى تحسين البيئات
لاي محادثات نوويه ربما
ابرز النقاط الخلافيه بين طهران وواشنطن
رفع العقوبات عن الحرس الثوري الايراني
وهو ما ترفضه واشنطن رفع جميع العقوبات
المفروضه على ايران بما في ذلك التي تم
فرضها بعد خروج ترامب من الاتفاق النووي
تقديم ضمانات لايران بان امريكا لن تنسحب
من الاتفاق من جديد قضيه عثور الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه على اثار لمواد
نوويه في مواقع غير مصرح بها تكتم ايران
عن تكثيف تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه 60% في
موقع اي ناتانز وفورتو
الجدل المتواصل بخصوص اتفاق تبادل للاسرى
من المواطنين الامريكيين الايرانيين
مناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من نيويورك عبر
سكايب توني بدران الباحث في مركز الدفاع
عن الديمقراطيه اهلا بك من طهران دكتور
محمد صالح صادق يا المدير المركز العربي
للدراسات الايرانيه اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من نيويورك معك استاذ
طوني في الواقع نحن نتحدث عن لقاء يقال
بانه الاول من نوعه لقاء مباشر بين
الوفدين الامريكي الايراني الا اذا كانت
هناك لقاءات سريه لم تعلن سابقا ولكن نحن
امام لقاء معلن مباشر صرح بتفاصيله سؤال
مطروح لماذا الان لماذا الان هذا اللقاء
من يحتاج الطرف الاخر اكثر في هذه المرحله
ايران او الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مساء الخير
ضيفك عفوا
هيدي هذا المسار
يعني خصوصا تحدي او تحديدا روبرت مالي
بلقاءات عبر
البعثه بالامم المتحده كان في كثير من
الاشاعات والتقارير انه كان هذا مسار عم
يجرب يفتحوا روبرت مالي وعم بصير لقاءات
هذه كانت من كذا شهر عم تطلع هذه الاشاعه
بالتالي هذا الخبر منه ابدا يعني
مفاجئ
هو الخبر كما تفضلت حضرتك بالاشاره تعمل
عليه الاطراف ناتي على تفاصيل ولكن لقاء
المباشر
اول مره منذ خمس سنوات وفدان امريكي
ايراني يلتقيان بطريقه مباشره لفتح مسارات
يمكن ان تكون سياسيه ولكن الابرز ملف
الابرز انساني تبادل الاسرى
تبادل الاسرى هو عاده مقدم يعني قصدي انه
هذه المحادثات جاريه منذ اشهر بعتقد بين
روبرتاني بالممثل الامم بالامم المتحده
وبالتالي هلا تم الاعلان عن ربما لقرب
الاقتراب الاعلان عن نوع من اتفاق ربما
اولا مثل ما قالت التبادل الاسرع يلي هو
شو بيعني يعني دفع فديه لرهائن محتجزه عند
ايران ومشان هيك عم بصير في الحديث عن
اموال العراق وكوريا الجنوبيه هي اللي عم
يدفعوا لهم شيء تقريبا شي سبعه مليارات
دولارات للايرانيه وهذا الشيء كمان
اللي هو شغلته
وشغلته كان ممثل لسياسه اوباما ولا تحديدا
لها اعاده التواضع مع ايران شغلته الوحيده
بهالاداره هو انه يرجع لهالاتفاق
قبل ان اذهب الى طهران حضرتك لما نتحدث
على صفقه تعلم بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على الاقل في تصريحاتها الرسميه
ترفض رفضا باتا ان يتم استرجاع اسراها تحت
طاوله صفقه ان تفرج عن اموال محتجزه ان
تعطي اموال مقابل الاسرى هذه المره بنعم
او لا هل ترضخ واشنطن لهكذا صفقه
مساء الخير لك
وللمشاهدين دعينا نفكك هذا الامر لانه في
عده قضايا في الاتفاق النووي في الاموال
الايرانيه المحتجزه وفيه قضيه تبادل
الاسرى او صفقه تبادل الاسرع اولا صفقه
تبادل الاسره تم التوصل اليها في العام
2020 في عهد الرئيس الايراني السابق حسن
روحاني لكن الاداره الامريكيه حينها لم
تقبل بتنفيذ هذه الصفقه وربطت تنفيذ هذه
الصفقه بالعوده للاتفاق النووي هذه النقطه
والايرانيون كانوا يصرون لقضايا انسانيه
ان تتم هذه الصفقه قبل التوصل او فكها من
العوده الى الاتفاق النووي النقطه الثانيه
الاموال الايرانيه هي ليست فديه تدفعها
الولايات المتحده لايران هذه هي اموال
ايرانيه مجمده لدى بنوك في كوريا وفي
العراق وفي اماكن اخرى في اليابان مثلا
وبالتالي هي ليست فديه تدفع قضيه هذه
الفديه يجب علينا ان نتحفظ عليها ونفكر
بها قبل ان نطلقها النقطه الثالثه هذا
التعليق للاستاذ توني صحيح خليه يعلق فقط
على هذه الكلمه لاستخدامه كلمه فديه
هلا فيه يقول ضيفك اللي بده اياه هي هاي
بس تدفعي مصاري شو هيدي مصاري اولا غير
لانه بسبب العقوبات لانه في التجارات غير
قانونيه عم تقوم فيها ايران يتم الحجز على
هذه الاطلاق هذه الاموال مقابل اطلاق سراح
صراح
حتى وان اختلفنا ربما على تسميات ولكن
تعريف ولكن حضرتك تعتبر بان هذه اموال
ايرانيه مستحقه اموال مجرده هذه اموال
ايرانيه حتى بالنسبه هذه ليست خرقت
العقوبات في كوريا
الرئيس الامريكي السابق كان قد
استثنى خمسه عشر دوله من استيراد النفط
الايراني وبالتالي ضمن هذا القانون ايران
صدرت النفط الى كوريا او اليابان وبالتالي
اليابان وكوريا والعراق لا يستطيعون
من ايران لنفط ولا كهرباء ولا غاز في
وكله مهرب يعني هذه لك على فرض ان العراق
يقبل ذلك لكن كوريا واليابان مطلقا لا
تقبل بان تشتري نفط مهرب النفض تصدير
النفط تم بصوره قانونيه وتم احتجاز هذه
الاموال الان هناك صفقه هذه الصفقه صفقه
تبادل رهائن هذه صفقه وبجانبها صفقه الحظر
الوداع الايرانيه طيب ولكن حضرتك سيد
صدقين
تعطي ريحه واضحه تحمل المسؤوليه للاداره
الامريكيه بانها هي التي ساهمت في عدم
حلحله هذا الملف ملف الاسرع لانها ربطت
بينه وبين الاتفاق النووي سيد طوني هل
يمكن للاداره الامريكيه ان تكون قد اعاقت
فعلا
امكانيه ايجاد حل حقيقي لازمه انسانيه
بربط هذه الازمه بموضوع سياسي اخر
مش الولايات المتحده هي اللي احتجست الرهج
يعني احتجاز الرهائن وبنعرف شو تاريخ
ايران باحتجاز الرهائن وليش تحت جزرا هائم
وليش دائما الاطلاق الصراحه عنها
بتبادل اسره
لعملاء لايراماه مثل ما شفنا كانوا متهمين
او مثبت اتهام يعني وحكم عليهم محاولات
تفجيرات ارهابيه واحد او ثالثا لعملاء
جواسيس والى ما هنالك في الولايات المتحده
اللي
كان
بهالاطار بين الولايات
كلها هيدي الملفات يعني الحكي عنا بطريق
انسانيه اوكي هلا دعايه الايرانيه انا بس
عم نقول دائما توقيتها هايدي والاطار يلي
دائما بالتنفيه هو اطار خصوصا مع الولايات
المتحده
للحصول على اموال من ناحيه وعاده بيكون
لنوع من تصريح فهمنا موضوع ربط هذا الملف
بالاموال ولكن ضيفي محدد هو يقول بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ربطت هذا
الملف مهما تكون تصريحات ايران مهما تكون
ما اعتبرته ادعاءات ايرانيه ولكن هو واضح
يقول بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ربطت
بين هذا الملف الانساني
بالتزامات بخصوص الاتفاق النووي اسال ان
كانت الاداره الامريكيه قادره على فعل ذلك
حتى وان كان الملف انساني
بتصور كان في نوع من يعني رغبه عارمه اذا
بدك من قبل روبرت مالي للعوده لهالاتفاق
بالتالي ممكن انه تم الربط او تم الربط
بصراحه ما عندي اي فكره بس منا اول مره
بيكون تم ربط فيها المفاوضات
في عده سوابق لهالشي انه دائما ببلش
المساله
لاعاده الاطلاق المفاوضات دايما بتبلش
بملف الرهائن انه هاي عاده تقول انه كعلان
عن نوايا حسنه واله والى ما هنالك من
تعابير لا نبلش نرجع نفوت يعني بالتالي
ايران بدها انه يندفع لها مصاري تترجع
لطاوله المفاوضات هيدي ثابته موجوده
بتاريخ المفاوضات على الاتفاق الفاشل تبع
باراك اوباما يلي هلا عم بيتم اعاده
حضرتك منذ قليل لما ربطت بين هذا الملف
الانساني والاتفاق النووي
تعلم حضرتك بان الغرب هو كذلك يطرح نفس
هذا الاتهام على ايران حضرتك الغرب يقول
بان ايران تستخدم ما يسمى بدبلوماسيه
الاسرى هي تستخدم هذه الدبلوماسيه للضغط
على ملفات اخرى تحتاجها ما ردك على مثل
هكذا اتهام
بدايه اسمحي لي انا لم اتحدث عن احداث جرت
في العصر الحجري انا اتحدث عن احداث وقعت
قبل سنتين في عشرين عشرين يعني الجانب
الامريكي هو الذي
وعباس عراقي كبير المفاوضين الايرانيين
قال بان التفاهم تم على تبادل المعتقلين
بين ايران وبين الجانب الغربي سواء كان
الاوروبي او الامريكي لكن الجانب الامريكي
رفض ان ينفذ هذه الصفقه وقال بانه مرتبط
بالعوده الى الاتفاق النووي هذا هذا هذه
يعني احداث جرت قبل سنتين وليس اتحدث
عن تحليل او تفسير سياسي النقطه الثانيه
ما يتعلق بهذه الصفقات يجب علينا ان نتذكر
بان قبل سنه من الان جاء
عن الانتخابات جديده سوف تعقد في عشرين
اربعه وعشرين وبالتالي المشكله ليست عند
الجانب الايراني المشكله عند الجانب
الامريكي دعيني اذكر ايضا لان كل الاتفاق
النووي والعوده الى الاتفاق النووي وقد تم
الاتفاق عليه وبالنقاط واحد اثنين ثلاثه
لكن الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه اداره
الرئيس بايدن رفضت اعطاء ضمانات بالنسبه
الى ايران من عدم انسحاب الجانب الامريكي
مره اخرى من اي اتفاق يمكن التواصل
بالاشاره متردده
حضرتك الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتحمل
مسؤوليه عرقله هذه
ان هذه
خلال السنتين الماضيتين لانها اداره كما
ذكرت متردده وغير شجاعه على اتخاذ قرارات
جريئه لحل ملف الاسرى لحل ملف الودائع
ومنه فيما بعد الانتقال الى الاتفاق
النووي وما رايك
اولا الاداره ما فيها تعطي ضمانات بهالشكل
لانه اذا اجى رئيس مثلا من الحزب الجمهوري
بيقدر يمزق الاتفاق ساعه البدو اللي كانت
يعني هيدي ايران ليش ايران بموقع كانت انه
قادره انه تعمل اطماطي بهالشكل هذا لانه
هالاداره يلي هي تكمله لاداره باراك
اوباما وهو روبرت مالي الممثل تبعها يعني
عند طوق
للعوده للاتفاق من ناحيه ومن ناحيه تانيه
عطيه الايرانيين
قدره على بيع
النصر
يعني ما نفذت العقوبات تركتني يرجعوا
لتخصيب الاورانيوم
يعني عاليه جدا ما
كانت لك يعني بالتالي الايرانيين لا احاول
مرتاحين بالتالي ما عندهم اي سرعه للعوده
للاتفاق لانه عم بياخذوا
الفوائد تبعه بلا ما يعوده للاتفاق
ترى بانه الاداره الايرانيه مرتاحه لان
هناك ازمات اقتصاديه وايران كانت واضحه
وصريحه وهي تقول بانه نحن نفتح المجال
لمحاوله تطبيع علاقاتنا وتصفير المشاكل
لمساعده اقتصادنا
ما في هيدي بتصور يعني حديثه دائما في
مشاكل بالاقتصاد الايراني ما في مشكل
عندهم اب يعني
سنه وين كانوا موجودين مع اداره ترامب وين
كانوا هلا قدرتهم على بيع النفط قدرتهم
على التعاون العسكري مع روسيا والى ما
هنالك قدرتهم حتى على يعني على العبث
بالمنطقه بدون اي رد بالخليج في البحر
الاحمر
بالمشرق الى ما هنالك
بموقعهن هن قادرين على الصبر
لاجبار اداره برهنه على طوقها انه بدها
ترجع باي سعر هلا
سياسيا
اداره صعب انها تبلعها هلا عم نوصل لمحل
لنوع من اعلان وهذا مشان هيك برجع بقول لك
لقصه للرهائن
لما تقول انا الاداره الايرانيه قادره ان
تصبر هذه ليست من المساوئ سيقول لك بعضهم
هذه من ايجابيات التعامل مع ملفات حساسه
ليس كذلك دكتور صاد باختصار شديد
يعني هذه الامور التي ذكرها صديقي ايطاني
هذه الامور شو سببها ارتفاع نسبه تخصيب
اليورانيوم كل هذا الذي ذكرها اعطاني هذه
سببها انسحاب الولايات المتحده من الاتفاق
النووي هذا الاتفاق استطاع ان يلجم طموحات
الايرانيه وفق نسبه تقصيب ثلاثه.67
المشكله في الولايات المتحده والسياسه
الخطا التي تستخدمها في الوقت الخطا هذه
مشكلتنا ليست مشكله ايران وانما مشكله كل
العالم والمجتمع الدولي من هذه السياسات
الامريكيه الخاطئه في كل حالات سيبقى
موضوع للمتابعه لنرى كيف سيكون موضوع حل
على الاقل موضوع الاسرى والشكركم جزيل
الشكر من نيويورك طوني بدران الباحث في
مركز الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات ومن طهران
الدكتور محمد صالح الصادقين مدير المركز
العربي للدراسات الايرانيه شكرا لكمما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات